Brasil acaba de vivir el momento más decisivo
de su historia democrática.
Las elecciones presidenciales celebradas en
octubre demostraron que Brasil está dividido
en dos: los seguidores del presidente Jair
Bolsonaro y todos los que están en su contra.
Al frente de éstos se situó Lula da Silva,
presidente brasileño a principios de siglo.
Muchos lo consideraban como el único capaz
de derrotar a Bolsonaro.
Y sí, tenían toda la razón.
En su discurso de la victoria, Lula se comprometió
a superar la división del país en dos bandos
y ser el presidente de todos los brasileños.
Desde luego, el resultado electoral fue terriblemente
apretado.
50,9% Lula, 49,1% Bolsonaro.
Que haya sido tan ajustado y que el todavía
presidente consiguiera un resultado mucho
mejor que el esperado en las encuestas hace
que nos hagamos muchas preguntas.
¿Cuáles han sido los principales logros
de Bolsonaro en estos 4 años?
¿Qué errores han provocado su derrota?
¿Cuáles serán los principales retos para
Lula da Silva en su nueva etapa presidencial?
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a dar respuesta
a estas preguntas, pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de Historia.
(LA COMUNIDAD DE BOLSONARO)
En la década de los 90 Brasil estaba anclado
en el pasado.
Su industria estaba protegida por aranceles
y existían prohibiciones a la importación
de muchos productos.
Además, el país afrontaba una acelerada
desindustrialización.
[Que es lo que pasa cuando tus industrias
no son competitivas]
Y eso no es todo.
Para colmo de males, acumulaba 4 décadas
de alta inflación.
Para acabar con esta situación, hace 30 años
el Gobierno de Itamar Franco puso en marcha
el Plan Real, un plan que más tarde desarrolló
el gobierno de Fernando Henrique Cardoso y
que supuso cambiar de moneda y aplicar una
reforma fiscal.
El Plan Real tuvo éxito y Brasil se transformó
en una de las economías emergentes más destacadas.
La pobreza comenzó a disminuir y la desigualdad
de ingresos se redujo.
Luego Lula da Silva disfrutó de unos años
de abundancia económica gracias al auge de
las materias primas en los mercados internacionales.
De esta forma Brasil se convirtió en 2010
en la séptima economía del mundo, prácticamente
empatada con la sexta como podéis ver aquí.
Sin embargo amigos, desde entonces ha caído
al duodécimo lugar de este ranking.
Cuando la bonanza petrolera llegó a su fin
las cosas empezaron a venirse abajo.
Además el Gobierno de Dilma Roussef fue letal
para la economía brasileña y esta entró
en una profunda recesión.
Incluso la mayor empresa del país, el gigante
petrolero estatal, Petrobras, estuvo contra
las cuerdas y cerca de quebrar.
El descontento de la gente impulsó a una
de las figuras políticas más polémicas
de los últimos años.
Estamos hablando por supuesto de Jair Bolsonaro.
Su discurso populista cautivó a millones
de brasileños cansados de los abundantes
escándalos de corrupción que azotaban al
Partido de los Trabajadores después de 16
años de Gobierno.
Ahora bien, uno de los mayores aciertos del
presidente Bolsonaro fue incorporar a Paulo
Guedes como una especie de superministro para
Asuntos Económicos.
(Paulo Guedes es doctor en Economía por la
Universidad de Chicago, institución de referencia
para el liberalismo económico.
Desde que se convirtió en ministro, impulsó
una agenda centrada en promover las privatizaciones,
simplificar las regulaciones laborales y reducir
la burocracia.
Una misión imposible de partida ya que, según
datos del Banco Mundial, Brasil tiene una
de las legislaciones tributarias más complejas
e ineficientes del mundo.
Concretamente se sitúa en el pues 184 del
ranking del Banco Mundial que mide a 190 sistemas
tributarios.)
La reforma laboral impulsada por el tándem
Bolsonaro – Guedes ha tenido buenos resultados.
La tasa de desempleo de Brasil alcanzaba el
12% cuando ambos alcanzaron el poder.
Actualmente y a pesar del coronavirus esta
se ha reducido por debajo del 9%, la cifra
más baja desde 2015.
Otra de las cartas jugadas por Guedes fue
la de apostar por las privatizaciones para
disminuir la deuda pública.
Para convencer a los brasileños, Bolsonaro
lo ha tenido fácil.
Pero claro, tampoco es que fuera complicado
mejorar la gestión económica de sus predecesores.
Ahora bien, este deseo de reducir el tamaño
de la maquinaria estatal tropezó con la realidad.
Cierto es que llevó a cabo la mayor privatización
en 2 décadas, pero al final no se atrevió
con la petrolera Petrobras.
Así que básicamente todo se limitó a una
privatización parcial de Eletrobras, la empresa
estatal encargada de la generación de electricidad
en el país.
Una privatización que atrajo la inversión
del fondo soberawno de Singapur y del fondo
de pensiones canadiense.
También permitió la inversión privada en
materia de agua y alcantarillado.
Pero sea como sea, lo importante es que, por
unas cosas y otras, los resultados llegaron.
(La mejor noticia para Brasil es que después
de una década anodina en materia de crecimiento
económico, el país volvió a cosechar unas
cifras razonablemente buenas, al menos teniendo
en cuenta que hablamos de Brasil, una economía
terriblemente burocrática y hostil para los
negocios incluso para los cánones de Latinoamérica.
Pues bien, la pandemia lastró a Brasil un
4% en 2020.
Pero en 2021 cosechó un alza del PIB de 4,6%.
Y en 2022 en el momento de las elecciones
el crecimiento interanual seguía estando
por encima del 3%.
Estos buenos datos y un discurso tremendamente
polarizado ayudaron a conformar alrededor
del presidente una comunidad de auténticos
fanáticos: el bolsonarismo.)
Sin embargo, un momento amigos, no es oro
todo lo que reluce.
Porque los números son razonablemente buenos,
sí, pero lo cierto es que la economía ha
crecido gracias en gran medida a las políticas
de estímulo del Gobierno.
A la vista de las encuestas, Bolsonaro apartó
la teoría económica y sacó toda su artillería
para lograr la remontada.
Aprobó un programa de ayuda con impuestos
más bajos a los combustibles, la electricidad,
el gas y el transporte público.
También apostó por mejorar las prestaciones
sociales.
La excusa: como podéis imaginar, la inflación.
El motivo, como bien suponéis, dar un regalito
a los votantes.
No olvidéis que para los políticos, los
brasileños pobres solamente tienen una cosa
que tiene tanto valor como el de los ricos:
su voto.
Así que para lograr este objetivo Bolsonaro
se lanzó a prorrogar e incluso ampliar medidas
sociales que puso en marcha con motivo de
la pandemia.
N1 (Bolsonaro eleva Auxílio Brasil de R$
400 para R$ 600)
Sin duda fue su medida estrella.
Estamos hablando de que esta subida del 50%
llevó Auxilio Brasil a unos 110 euros mensuales.
Además, después de la primera vuelta de
las elecciones se comprometió a prorrogar
esta ayuda durante 2023.
La factura de todo esto no es ninguna broma:
ahora mismo Auxilio Brasil lo están recibiendo
21 millones de familias brasileñas.
Así que, real arriba, real abajo, Bolsonaro
comprometió ayudas por valor de 50.000 millones
de euros, incluyendo nuevos programas de condonación
de deuda y líneas de crédito.
Sin embargo amigos, todo esto no fue suficiente
para Bolsonaro.
Tenía muchos errores que enmendar y la campaña
electoral contra Lula fue como juntar a hinchas
del Palmeiras con los del Corinthians.
Atentos.
T2 (LAS DOS TORRES)
La gestión de Bolsonaro ha tenido sombras
importantes.
Negar la importancia del covid-19 convirtió
a Brasil en el segundo país del mundo con
más muertes por coronavirus con casi 700.000
fallecidos.
Restar importancia al repunte de la tala del
Amazonas tampoco parece ser la mejor carta
de presentación en una escena internacional
dominada por las preocupaciones ambientales.
Y defender un concepto anticuado del papel
de la mujer en las sociedades modernas es
un obstáculo para que buena parte del electorado
te vote.
Aún así estuvo a punto de ganar la reelección
en un enfrentamiento entre las dos figuras
más importantes de la política brasileña
en lo que llevamos de siglo.
Porque Lula también genera rechazo.
(El expresidente Lula da Silva fue encarcelado
tras ser acusado por corrupción dentro del
gran escándalo Lava Jato que se produjo alrededor
de la petrolera estatal Petrobras.
Pasó 19 meses en prisión antes de ser liberado
por el Tribunal Supremo, que anuló todas
las sentencias contra Lula al entender que
este asunto escapaba de la jurisdicción del
juez que le había condenado.
En otras palabras, Lula fue liberado por un
defecto técnico en el proceso judicial al
que fue sometido, no porque el Supremo le
considerara inocente de las acusaciones en
su contra, algo por lo que nunca será juzgado
porque los hechos ya están prescritos.)
A favor de Lula ha jugado el recuerdo entre
los votantes.
Durante su presidencia mejoró considerablemente
la calidad de vida de millones de brasileños
y tenéis que pensar que por mucho money que
Bolsonaro soltara justo antes de las elecciones,
los que reciben las ayudas son los mismos
que están enfadados por la subida de la inflación.
En cualquier caso, como os podéis imaginar,
hablamos de dos políticos que no dejan indiferente
a nadie.
Y eso se ha notado en la campaña electoral,
donde se han sobrepasado todos los límites.
Ahora bien, si Bolsonaro tiene fama de faltar
el respeto a sus rivales políticos, no os
penséis que Lula se ha quedado atrás.
N2 (Brasil: juez prohíbe a Lula asociar a
Bolsonaro con canibalismo en campaña electoral.
DW)
La campaña electoral ha sido más sucia que
los marcajes a Neymar.
Y es una pena porque se necesitaban propuestas
para reactivar la economía brasileña.
El país ha perdido el rumbo y solo lo sostiene
el auge de su sector agroindustrial gracias
al apetito voraz de China por la soja y el
resto de productos que ofrece el campo brasileño.
Esta es una historia de éxito ya que Brasil
se ha convertido en el tercer mayor exportador
mundial de productos agrícolas detrás de
Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea.
Pero esto no basta para el gigante de Sudamérica.
El declive de su industria mantiene una tendencia
iniciada hace décadas.
Mirad la evolución.
Más allá del sector petróleo y la agroindustria
que ya supone el 28% del PIB, el resto del
sector industrial va de mal en peor.
El problema es que la economía brasileña
no está generando empleos bien remunerados
como los perdidos en la industria.
Y después de una campaña sin propuestas,
parece que estas cuestiones no importan a
ningún político ni a sus votantes, entre
los que tienen mucha incidencia las masas
fanatizadas cuyo único objetivo es derrotar
a sus oponentes.
Ahí es donde encaja que haya seguidores de
Bolsonaro rogando al Ejército que dé un
golpe de Estado contra Lula.
Parecen estar dispuestos a todo.
Aunque no a tanto como algunos quieren hacernos
creer.
N3 (Los partidarios de Bolsonaro utilizan
sus móviles para pedir un golpe “extraterrestre”.
El País)
Algunos medios de comunicación prestigiosos
han caído en la tentación de dar verosimilitud
a esta noticia con tal de ridiculizar a los
seguidores de Bolsonaro.
Millones de brasileños estarían encantados
de que E.T.
le curara el tobillo a Neymar como si fuera
el dedo de Elliot.
Pero amigos, como tantas veces ocurre, la
realidad es mucho menos interesante que la
noticia.
Prensa difundió fake news sobre manifestantes
en Porto Alegre)
Aunque, ojo, que tampoco hablamos de poca
cosa.
Esas linternas de móviles dirigidas hacia
el cielo son una manifestación más de ciudadanos
brasileños para pedir de nuevo un golpe de
estado a las fuerzas armadas, pero no a los
alienígenas.
Todo para lucir un SOS FA, que pudiera captar
un dron desde el cielo, pero no El Halcón
Milenario.
Mirad.
A pesar de todo esto, parece que Bolsonaro
ha aceptado la derrota y no se va a marcar
un Capitolio al estilo Trump.
La mala noticia para Lula es que aún así
dirigir Brasil le resultará mucho más difícil
que la última vez que estuvo en el cargo.
El país está más dividido que entonces
y sus finanzas públicas están en peor estado.
Sin embargo, es el momento de que Brasil afronte
los cambios estructurales y avance hacia un
modelo productivo que siente las bases del
crecimiento económico en el largo plazo.
¿Cuáles serán los principales retos de
Lula?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T3 (EL RETORNO DE LULA)
Lula da Silva quiere volver a poner al Estado
en el centro de la economía brasileña.
Pra ello planea utilizar el gasto público
para estimular el crecimiento, especialmente
en el desarrollo de infraestructuras a imitación
del Build Back Better del presidente estadounidense
Biden.
También quiere ampliar los planes sociales,
como el programa Bolsa Familia.
Sin embargo amigos, para ello tiene que sortear
un importante obstáculo: el tope de gasto
público que introdujo hace 6 años el presidente
Temer para frenar la crisis que vivía entonces
el país.
Esto exige una enmienda constitucional que
según algunos expertos debe ser aprobada
por el Congreso antes del 10 de diciembre.
De momento Lula ya ha indicado cuánta pasta
necesita para hacer realidad sus planes.
(El equipo de Lula busca eximir 32.400 millones
de dólares del tope de gasto)
Y ahora sé que muchos estaréis pensando:
ya estamos.
¡Se van a gastar lo que no tienen!
Y sí, es verdad, pero es que Bolsonaro fue
el primero que se saltó el tope de gasto.
Primero a cuenta de la pandemia, pero luego
pensando ya directamente en cómo ganar las
elecciones.
La cuestión ahora es cómo planea Lula pagar
el gasto extra que propone, esos 32.000 millones
de dólares.
Lula habla de políticas que impulsen el mercado
interno para aumentar la producción y el
consumo.
Para conseguirlo habla de elevar los programas
sociales, la inversión pública y apoyar
el desarrollo de infraestructura.
Sostiene que generando unos ingresos más
altos, aumentará la recaudación de impuestos.
Pero..
queréis que os diga; es el milagro de los
panes y los peces en su versión brasileña.
La subida de la recaudación no será suficiente
y todo indica que tirará de deuda pública.
El problema es que las finanzas de Brasil
no están igual que cuando Lula dejó la presidencia.
Lula no tendrá mucho margen de actuación.
El 80% del presupuesto se va en sueldos de
los empleados públicos y pensiones cuando
en la mayoría de países estas partidas no
llegan al 60%.
El gasto público se acerca al 40% del PIB,
una proporción similar a la de muchos países
ricos.
Pero la calidad de los servircios que ofrecen
a sus ciudadanos está a años-luz de lo que
reciben los brasileños.
El país necesita muchas reformas y la primera
de la lista es una reforma fiscal.
En este aspecto la administración de Bolsonaro
fracasó en el intento.
Ahora es el turno de Lula, que quiere enfocarse
en combatir la desigualdad y mejorar la redistribución
de ingresos.
Todo un reto para Lula, que por fortuna lo
tendrá más fácil en otras materias.
(Lula da Silva va a aprovecharse del legado
del tándem Bolsonaro-Guedes.
A pesar de que su partido criticó duramente
la reforma laboral, en la campaña electoral
no se ha hablado de derogarla sino de modificarla
con pequeños retoques.
Lula también criticó las privatizaciones.
Pero volver a nacionalizar Eletrobras tendría
un coste político muy superior a los millones
de dólares que necesitaría.
Supondría crear inseguridad jurídica para
las inversiones en Brasil, algo que perjudicaría
otros proyectos gubernamentales, como las
asociaciones público-privadas para el desarrollo
de infraestructuras.)
A pesar de su discurso de izquierdas, Lula
ha sabido moverse hacia el centro, tal y como
demuestra que como vicepresidente haya elegido
a Geraldo Alckmin, antiguo líder del centroderecha.
Además, no tiene mayoría parlamentaría
y eso complicará y mucho cualquier cambio
radical.
Por eso, todo apunta a que Lula se va a centrar
en mejorar los planes sociales y sobre todo
a sacar adelante una agenda verde que, por
ejemplo, reactive el Pacto Amazónico para
proteger la selva tropical.
A eso y a desarrollar una agenda exterior
mucho más activa en la región.
Lula ha dicho por activa y por pasiva que
la integración regional será una de sus
grandes obsesiones.
Pero sea como sea, quizás realmente el principal
desafío del nuevo Gobierno brasileño será
explicar cómo pagará sus grandes promesas
de gasto.
Seguramente tenga que sustituir el tope de
gasto por otro mecanismo más flexible pero
capaz de mantener la confianza de los mercados
en la sostenibilidad de la deuda pública.
Claro que con un Congreso en contra eso no
parece una tarea nada sencilla.
En todo caso en esto tendrá mucho que decir
la persona que Lula elija como su ministro
de Economía.
Parece que ya tiene nombre y apellidos.
(Lula se inclina por el exalcalde Haddad para
impulsar la economía de Brasil)
[adache] Haddad es una opción de la izquierda
moderada.
Como alcaldewee de São Paulo entre 2013 y
2016, redujo el déficit presupuestario y
aseguró para la ciudad una calificación
crediticia de grado de inversión.
No se deja llevar por políticas populistas
y eso es una buena noticia en Brasil.
Pero ahora la pregunta es para vosotros.
¿Creéis que un presidente como Lula da Silva
es lo que necesita Brasil?
¿O pensáis que Bolsonaro se había ganado
tener un segundo mandato para desarrollar
al completo sus políticas?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, si te ha resultado interesante
el vídeo dale a like y no olvides suscribirte
a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.